en belfast Este muro aún separa algunas
zonas nacionalistas y unionistas testigo
de un conflicto que dejó 3600 muertos y
50.000 heridos la batalla más Sangrienta
de la historia reciente del Reino Unido
durante tres décadas republicano se
unionistas se enfrentaron Hasta que el
acuerdo de paz del viernes Santo firmado
en 1998 puso fin a la violencia
interreligiosa preveía el reparto del
poder entre los protestantes que
deseaban permanecer en el Reino Unido y
los católicos republicanos que querían
la reunificación con la República de
Irlanda 25 años después Peter que perdió
a su padre a los 14 años quieren mirar
hacia el futuro
25 años después del acuerdo de viernes
Santo Irlanda del Norte es un lugar
mucho más diverso y creo que es hora en
mi opinión de trazar una línea en el
pasado y seguir adelante aunque algunos
los políticos no parezcan dispuestos a
hacerlo
pero para algunas personas el Duelo es
más difícil como estos familiares de
víctimas del conflicto reunidos frente
al edificio del gobierno británico en
belfast para exigir justicia
quiero que alguien rinda cuentas por el
asesinato de mi hermano saben Quién mató
a mi hermano yo sé su nombre Ellos saben
su nombre quiero que se le
responsabilice del asesinato de mi
hermano y que sea juzgado
según el gobierno británico cerca de
1200 muertes siguen bajo investigación
pero las interminables batallas
judiciales podrían acabar pronto el año
pasado Londres presentó un proyecto de
ley para conceder la amnistía y el
retiro de los cargos a quienes cooperen
un proyecto de ley denunciado por todos
los partidos no irlandeses